[Music]
joining me today is a new zealand-born
author speaker and founder and
headmistress of Michaela Community
School a free school established in
London all the way back in 2014
Katherine verbal saying welcome to the
Rubin report hi hi I'm very happy to
have you here oh thank you having me
I have heard a rumor that you sometimes
play my videos in your classrooms well I
don't know about the classrooms but
among stuff yeah among staff in the
school somewhere in the school yeah in
the school definitely we're all demands
thank you for our two controversial to
play in the class yeah I think so I
think so there's so much I want to talk
to you about about education your your
personal sort of political evolution all
the things that you've been through so I
always like finding out a little bit
about somebody's history at the top and
you come from a long line of teachers
and some interesting background stuff so
tell me a little bit about young
Katherine well um I mean my parents my
father is Indian Guyanese my mum is
drank and black Jamaican I say that
because the whole race thing is
important you know bizarrely because
these days you know people are so much
more interested in who said it as
opposed to what is being said and you
know some what some random person set up
a Wikipedia page for me and there was
this kind of major argument going on
between my detractors and and the people
who support me people who support me one
of the truth to be there the people who
didn't like me wanted it too wanted me
to be Indian rather than black because
black was kind of a bigger victim to
discredit me they needed to push me up
the the victim pole you know yes so they
might hit hard following the oppression
Olympics yeah I know exactly and so you
know my mother was a nurse my father
taught at University and came from you
know dirt poverty in Guyana but is one
of those extraordinary people who made
something of himself through hard work
and I was born in New Zealand and then I
grew up in Canada and then I've now been
in London for you know nearly 30 years
and I went to Oxford University
and I've been a teacher ever since and I
was a very left-wing teacher a very
typical teacher in that way yeah and I
used to write a blog which was called to
miss with love based on the book and
film sir - sir with love you know Sidney
Poitier it was in the film and I wrote
this blog you know a few times a week
I'd go home and write about how little
Johnny had his money stolen and that
kind of thing things that made me really
upset about the education system and
wait let's pause for a second before you
get to get to the point where you sort
of woke up and got in trouble and I'll
have people fighting on your Wikipedia
page so what what sort of education did
you have that pushed you towards leftism
or was it just just how it was kind of
like where do those ideas come from do
that did that come from school yeah that
come from family was it I suppose my
family yeah you know it's really
interesting because I think ethnic
minorities really are small see
conservative naturally but because the
black vote normally goes to the left my
family was no different from from a
typical family you know ethnic family in
that sense and so I was brought up in a
left-wing household yeah why do you
think they generally vote small to see
conservative or that bit why not vote
why do they internally either think it
or have been taught to thank you I think
they come from small see conservative
background so when I say that just the
belief in and pulling yourself up from
your own boots but your own bootstraps
hard work will get you somewhere
personal responsibility being stoical
when things are difficult but the kind
of thing that makes people successful
yeah exactly and and I think minorities
especially the ones who've been
immigrants moved somewhere knew they
believe in giving their children a
better life and in working hard in order
to be able to do so so it fits with them
okay so now so you come from a small
seed conservative family what kind of
voting left yes
and then that's right you start right
and I'm a teacher so everyone I know is
on the Left and I don't speak to any
conservative people because that's how
it is there's this big divide and nobody
ever speaks to each other I didn't know
any conservative people or the way
conservative people thought and then I
was writing this blog and that's where I
started meeting
conservative people and I say meat on my
blog so Twitter didn't exist in those
days people would have discussions on
the blog comment section and all these
left wingers would come on and start
attacking me and telling me how awful I
was with the stories that I was writing
and how could I judge the education
system as I was judging it and all these
conservatives would come on and defend
me and I'd be saying to the left wingers
no no I wanted well I'm one of you who
you know I'm with you I'm a good person
and they'd say no you're a right winger
and I think well of course I'm not on
the right of course I'm not conservative
I'm a good person
so how did I possibly be conservative
and the Conservatives would come on and
say I think you'll find that you are and
over years of me writing and me
insisting that I was on the Left I came
to realize that I wasn't my instincts
the things that I valued the values it
was that those basic values of personal
responsibility and and and and and
perseverance and and and being happy
with competition and all that kind of
stuff I liked and then I realized I came
to realize slowly and and then I met a
few people so like I met you would be
interested because you always interested
in meeting people who don't think like
you yeah I met this guy so there was
this guy used to come onto my blog
called
he British national party member so he
was he was just I mean people call it
the fascist party you know and in the
day they had a lot more power than they
do nowadays and so he was part of the
BNP and I would let him come on my blog
so all of these kind of lefties were
outraged how can you let him come on
your blog you need to ban him but I
always thought what do you mean can't
worry about just just comment it's a
common dangerous con he would comment
and get into discussions sometimes of me
and sometimes with other people and some
of the left wingers would refuse to talk
to him at all you know and they get
really angry with me but you didn't take
that I should just say you're not
allowed to be on here and then you know
I
he was on there for a just this is over
years and then and then I said you know
it'd be really interesting to meet you
because you're very different from
anybody I know and so I met this guy and
you know I mean he was a racist you know
I mean he was you know the things that
he believed about
black people and so on he was a racist
but you know what I always say is some
of my best friends are racist you know
it's like Avenue Q you know the the
musical with you know everyone's a
little bit racist and people are racist
on different levels you know sometimes
you're really racist sometimes just a
little bit racist anyway I met with him
he was wearing a suit he's a young white
guy um wearing a suit nice shoes and and
he went he took me for lunch he paid
from lunch
so the racist took you for life that's
right that's right that's what's so
interesting about life right yeah and um
so we went for lunch and he was hobbling
along and I said you know you were right
he said oh you know the thing is I
bought this Sutan and these shoes
because I was meeting with you and you
know you went to Oxford University and I
figured I gotta get dressed up you know
but the shoes are new and they're really
hurting my feet and I thought isn't that
interesting here's this racist yeah who
was taking me for lunch who's wearing
new shoes that he's bought because I've
been to Oxford you know and that's
what's so interesting about life is that
it's not as easy as some of the left put
people you know you're a racist you're
not a racist you're a good person you're
a bad person you're this it's not like
that
there's a whole variety of different
ways of seeing people and learning from
people yeah and um and was he able to
learn from you after that well we met a
second time and you know I mean when I
say he was right I mean like he was
telling me about how that morning he'd
been to see his girlfriend and they have
a toddler and he'd gone to see her and
see the the the baby she wouldn't let
him hold the baby because she knew that
he was coming to see me and she said
you're gonna contaminate him that's true
racism is that's like truly exactly yeah
exactly um but you know he was a good
guy in so many other ways and that's
what that's what's interesting about
life is what I'd say is that nobody's
perfect and people changed their minds
you know I think about my parents who
lived in the same house for 46 years in
Toronto and there was a man called mr.
snow who lived opposite them and when he
moved when they moved into the area it
was all white and he was outraged
because he was a racist
and he thought no way I don't want these
people living there and over the years
over the 46 years they got to know each
other and they became friends and in the
end mr. snows wife you know she she got
cancer and she died and mr. snow I had
to depend on my parents for a whole lot
of help and and my parents loved mr.
snow and mr. snow loved them you know
things can change people can change and
when mr. snow died my parents moved
house because the the community they
lived in and had had died with mr. snow
and this was a man who was so racist he
didn't want them to live there you know
isn't it personally powerful too I mean
I can feel it when you're saying it that
when you can accept some people for all
their flaws that it actually allows you
to figure out how to grow instead of
just other member ever even even if they
might do that to a whole set of people
for awful reasons yeah well and they can
change
I mean people change their minds you
know I have this quote in my office from
Muhammad Ali that says you know if a man
at 40 still thinks the same way as when
he was 20 then he's lost 20 years of his
life you know and thank God we can
change I mean when I think about how I
used to think you know and how I think
now well that's what life's all about
right so okay so let's back up to some
of those ideas because so you were you
were a lefty and then you started
teaching in inner-city schools that's
right that's when you started waking up
and that's what sort of forced you to or
of course you were led you to write the
blog yeah what were some of the ideas
that you were seeing specifically that
you realize wow this is not working in
these schools yeah yeah so so one of the
big things that I used to think before
going into teaching and everyone used to
just accept was that black kids failed
at school because white teachers are
racist the system is racist the white
teachers are racist and that's why black
kids are failing a lot of teachers go
into teaching for racist purposes now
you think well this is what's so crazy I
was thinking but I've met hundreds
thousands of teachers not one of them
has ever said to me I'm a racist and I
want to stop black kids from from
succeeding in fact they are killing
themselves you know working all hours
giving everything that they can to the
job
and I started to question the kinds of
things that the the normal the normal
way of seeing things was what I was
being told and it wasn't just that you
know in which we might get into later
about teaching methods and about
discipline and so on the kinds of
leaders I worked in the whole second
half gonna be on your solution okay so
yeah I started to question all of that
and I went there was this black
achievement kind of conference that used
to happen once a year which was about
improving black achievement and how what
do we do raising black achievement and
there was a labor so that's our left
political party black woman MP so one of
our politicians who used to run this
thing and I went along and I took one of
the white teachers who I worked with and
he was older than me he's retired now
and he'd been doing this for 25 years
and given everything to the job and I
took him along and these people were
standing up on stage essentially saying
that white teachers were racist and I
was so embarrassed I was so humiliated
that I had taken this man giving up his
Saturday to go and sit and be told that
he's a racist when he had given
everything to these black boys so we
worked in this boys school and it was
mainly black boys in this school and and
I was just I was mortified so gradually
I started to change my mind on these
sorts of things and then I started to
see that there was it had to do with our
expectations of kids it had to do with
our our expectations of parents it had
to do with the kinds of values that the
way we were giving them so if we were
saying to them poor you you're a victim
life is so difficult you're black you'll
never be able to get anywhere then it's
quite hard for the black inner city boy
go oh well you know actually it's about
working hard it's about we always say at
school even when it's difficult
especially when it's difficult you do
what's right right and as opposed to
saying that's difficult I can't do it
right except before michaela that that
business of even when it's difficult
especially when it's difficult that that
value that that that business of
believing in hard work
I didn't see it so much and and we would
give kids excuses we would give kids
excuses to fail and I wouldn't do it in
my classroom and the kids behave for me
and the kids learned with me and of
course I'm not the only teacher was
doing that their teachers all over the
place and their own classrooms were
doing that what I what I wanted what did
the administration think of you because
it sounds like you know oh we've got you
and obviously as you said you weren't
the only one but we've got people
pushing against the very because that's
the fabric of what these schools
eventually become that it's not it's not
on them it's on the system that is
ruined people where they've even begun
yeah yeah and they're poor I mean I
don't suppose people realize what I was
saying you know I mean I'm you're
talking to kids privately do your own
thing and if kids are behaving for you
and you're getting good results and then
then the principal loves you you know
it just works and people don't know why
I don't even sure I realized why you
know you just you build up an experience
over years and you know what works with
the kids and how you get them on board
and how you show them that you're in
charge and and then you teach them
properly and they love you for it
do you realize that your political
evolution was happening at the exact
same time
because it was sort of very personal in
the classroom but then that you were
evolving yeah would have been in another
sense
oh it is for a lot of people i when
people come up to me on the street or
email me they're saying you know
something's happening at work I'm
dealing with this and now it's starting
to make me think differently about
politics or are used to always vote
Democrat but you know something happened
here my family we got in a conversation
and now I'm starting to think something
else is a little bit different well that
was the blog yes so it was the
Conservatives on my blog that I was
realizing I'm agreeing with you and I'm
not agreeing with the left wingers on
the blog and it was then that I just
thought well maybe I am just a
conservative I accepted it and then in
you know accepted the idea of being
conservative and then in 2010 I voted
conservative which was a major deal for
me
and it was funny because you know after
I did that I remember this is after I
ended up in the press and so on I was
speaking to a friend of mine
I said to her and she's Indian and I
said to her you know it will obviously
you've seen me the press and everything
and how I voted conservative and she
said well you know I have something to
tell you Catherine
I voted conservative too and that's the
thing people are doing this on the can
admit to it it's so crazy so I voted
conservative in May 2010 and then in
October 2010 I was invited to go to the
Conservative Party conference to to give
a speech yes and that's like a
convention you guys have conventions
here and um I was a teacher I never
really took much notice of political
things I mean I I didn't I was a bit
naive and a bit stupid to be honest and
anyway I went along and I gave this
speech which the audience really liked
and and then I ended up all over the
press yeah so this is the speech really
that changed everything that changed my
life yeah for the worse at the time I
mean I think now I can look back and say
it was for the better in many ways or
you know at least yeah I mean I every
cloud has a silver lining and my silver
lining has been has been a good one
because I've made it into the silver
lining but I could have been destroyed
by it quite easily I mean in the end I
ended up without a job I was told that I
would never get a job in the state
education ever again yeah could you just
lay out some of the things that you
talked about in the speech right so I
talked about black kids failing and that
I talked about I talked about that's not
expecting enough of kids and how we are
constantly making excuses for them and
how we label them with things like anger
management or you know dyslexia or all
these kind of labels that we give the
kids oh he can't possibly believe he's
he's got issues that's what we always
say they have we they have particular
needs and we have to meet their needs as
opposed to just expecting them to behave
everybody has different needs nobody we
can't expect anything of them and that's
just the norm it's the norm so I I
talked about all this I talked about
competition and how it was needed in
schools that kids need to feel as if
they're competing against somebody else
and so on they need to feel like they're
being inspired to work hard
as opposed to being indulged and
constantly let off the hook because well
it's not your fault
your parents are divorced it's not your
fault because you live on an estate and
your black and your mom is a single mom
and you can't possibly do your homework
I mean I don't understand you know like
and that was because over the years you
know I'd visited I'd worked for a summer
once in South Africa
I'd been to see schools in China and
Brazil and India and all of these
countries where the kids were far poorer
and yet they were walking five miles
getting to school and working really
hard so why was it that those kids could
do it and apparently our kids couldn't
do it you know so that was why I
questioned it and I said all of this
stuff at the conference and the
Conservatives liked what I said yeah cuz
nobody ever says this sort of thing and
then as I say it was out of a job and
then I thought what do I do
how does that happen so you give this
speech you're fired the next day well no
I resigned it again but it was just
untenable like yeah the press I was I
was everywhere
it was like one of those Hollywood films
I couldn't go outside my door because
they were pressed waiting outside to
talk to me yeah like I said
responsibilities a thing go get her this
is what's so crazy all I said was
ultimately I was saying that the
education system was broken and people
wouldn't have that and the thing is I do
feel it's like the emperor's new clothes
which is that everybody knows that
there's a problem with the education
system but nobody is willing to say it
and I got hundreds if not thousands of
emails from teachers all over the
country saying thank god someone said
something thank you for saying something
I won't tell you my name yeah I can't
tell you my name because I'll lose my
job because they're all terrified right
so so yeah so I am I then thought about
the private sector for a bit but then I
thought I love working with
disadvantaged kids I love working in the
inner city this is what I do this is
what I know not I'm not giving up so we
had just you've had charter schools in
America for a long time we it was only
in 2010 that free schools which are
charter schools started in you know
there was the possibility of setting one
up so I decided to set up my own school
and I got a group of people together and
then we started trying to set it up now
this was not easy
because I had a lot of people who hated
me yeah I mean I still have a lot of
people hate me except I do think the
number is probably reduced or at least
they've just left me alone actually I
don't know if the numbers reduced I
think they just leave me alone I think
at some point they see that you keep
going and you keep becoming successful
and then they'll always find someone new
to feed and to scare but it's like they
you know you mean like at some point
they're like wow yeah we haven't got her
yet that's it and then they run out
they're not into hard work really so
they kind of move on to an easier target
yeah I need these I am a more it's
harder now because because I have the
school and it's really hard although
they do try you know when we were trying
to set up the school I was used to say
gosh it's like we're like making nuclear
bombs I mean all we're doing is setting
up a school I mean we would we would we
would have parents evenings so first of
all I'd be out in the street handing out
flyers running into hairdressers and
saying does anybody have any children
who might want to go to the secondary
school and you know women would be
coming out of their hair dryers saying
ok I'll have one other one going into
churches and mosques and temples and all
sorts and then we would have a parents
evening once we had it in the pub and
all these parents were arriving our
detractors are outside picketing they've
got like posters that saying Tory
teacher all sorts of insults the
screaming obscenities at me calling me
names and we have to hire a bouncer
because we were so worried about the
possible violence and then when I was
talking to the parent these parents
finding out about a school that's it and
there were all poor parents from the
inner city right so you got all these
black bums black single moms sitting
there trying to find out about this new
school and all these white middle-class
people and when we say middle-class we
mean people with money you guys use it
as a working you are when we say
middle-class you you guys say
middle-class we mean working-class when
I say middle-class I mean well-off
people so these white you know
well-educated well-off people are have
infiltrated and are sitting amongst all
of these inner-city people who are
wanting to find out about the school and
when I'm talking they're standing up and
shouting abuse deliberately because
they're trying to disrupt kind of like
when you do stuff and like the shaking
pennies and guards
we're gonna talk about that because I
know you had a little criticism of the
way I dealt with one of the issues there
related to education we'll get to that
but yeah so but let's just focus on that
for a second what do you think it is
about the intentions of those people I
try not to judge people's intentions I
try to judge their actions but these
these working-class and and I know
you're not into identity politics but
they happen to be white which you're
illustrating here that they're the ones
that are attacking yeah black mothers
that are trying to take care of their
kids
what is it that these people what do you
think they really think what why do you
think they really are so invested in
keeping everything the way it was
they'll demand they'll say that they're
for helping these people all the time
then they'll look at a system that does
not help these people then someone comes
in and says I'm gonna help these people
and there's a track record of doing it
yeah
and they hate you and then yeah yeah
they do and so just so I'm clear these
are white well-off people right these
are people who are who have everything
none of them have been privately
educated right I think it's because they
believe in making people equal but the
state should make people equal as
opposed to giving people equality of
opportunity because I'm all about giving
people equality of opportunity I want to
make it so that schools are so good that
everybody has an equal chance of making
something of themselves and changing
their stars right that's what I want to
do yeah they don't like that they want
these people to continue being not not
being successful
and then there's kind of these these
white knights in shining armor can come
down and the state can provide you with
money and a free apartment and and all
sorts of things and then they can sit at
dinner parties and feel very good about
themselves because well you know I vote
on the left and I'm a very good person
if it works so they're not interested in
whether or not it works they're
interested in feeling good about
themselves and they're they genuinely
believe that the state is going to make
things better for these people and free
schools charter schools while they are
state schools they break up the
education system right so the unions
aren't as powerful anymore and they very
much believed in the power of the unions
and they want them to have their
collective bargaining and if too many
schools break out of the system and
break up the system then it devalues
that
of the unions so I think that they
convinced themselves that what they're
doing is right even though there are all
these poor mums wanting to find out
about another option for their child and
they're desperate and when I say
desperate I've had mothers crying you
know in front of me crying saying I
don't want my child to get knifed I
don't want I want my child to have a
decent education so that maybe he'll
have a chance to get to university I
just want him to be safe right and and
then people are and then what they'll do
is they'll deny that that that that's
the case that there are schools where
children aren't safe they'll deny they
just they just lie there just bold-faced
lies about the system so what other kind
of pushback did you get as you were
creating the school like what what is it
like to you ok you fill out some
paperwork I assume them and now you
tried it you talked to some people and
maybe you talked to some teachers that
like minded people the administrators
and things but what's that like to go I
got to find a building I got to find
funding oh that's right so it's a total
nightmare
I mean really whenever any group comes
to me and says we want to set up a
school I always say okay well dig deep
right because you're gonna have to get
every bit of energy you got to be able
to push to run this I mean it took us
three years and it took us three years
to find a building there were so many
people against us and as you were saying
earlier I just kept going I mean I kind
of had to keep going because otherwise I
was gonna be able to do the job that I
love so I had to and eventually we found
this building I mean so first you apply
you have to go for a interviews you know
the panel interviews and blah blah and
you get approved and then you're looking
for a building and oh it's just all the
nightmare but um eventually we got this
building which you know isn't the
greatest building and when I say it's
not great you know there's no grass
there are no trees there's no car park
for the staff there's just the old car
park which is used as a playground for
the kids which is tiny you know it isn't
ideal but I always say it's the people
inside the building that matter and
we've made a real go of it and and it
you know it's it's great it's it's it's
and and what is great but everybody
really is great and this is where
you know I'm really you know I feel
really optimistic is that we have five
to ten teachers from all over the world
to come and visit the school every
single day mainly from the UK but we get
Americans Canadians Australians New
Zealanders I mean and they come because
they've heard about us through social
media and they want to see what we do
and then we get loads of letters from
teachers from principals who say I've
taken these ideas and I've put them in
my school and it's really helped and
it's made things better for our kids so
I feel like we're not just having impact
in our school on our kids but on on kids
all over the world you know
[Music]